die bundesregierung hat die ganze zeit
gesagt wir wollen mehr machen und
deshalb wenn wir es schaffen vor
weihnachten einmütig noch gemeinsam
verschärfung sondern schließen sind wir
dabei wir hatten auch schon überlegt ob
man denn die schulferien etwas früher
beginnen lassen kann
aber das muss man eben sehen wird er das
glas ist das auch vor allerdings ist das
nur solange sinnvoll wie wir sagen die
alternative muss möglich sein zu hause
zu bleiben und wenn wir das realisieren
können dann kann das eine sinnvolle
maßnahme sein ansonsten bleibt dabei
haben wir auch nach der letzten mpk
gesagt dann müssen diejenigen die hohe
insolvenzen haben eben auch von sich aus
handeln also es gibt nicht die
möglichkeit zu sagen wenn wir keine
bundesweit einheitlichen maßmann machen
waren wir nicht sondern das was also
macht wenn schleswig holstein halten die
mit machte oder meck pomm dann machen
wir es halt an einer sie haben gerade
busse und bahnen schon angesprochene wir
haben uns sehr viel mühe gegeben ja auch
bei der deutschen bahn was zu machen
haben wir jetzt dieses verändert
reservierungssystem ja es gerade da wo
man wirklich länger auch vielleicht in
einem umfeld sitzt das dann nur jeder
zweite platz reserviert werden kann das
finde ich sehr sehr sinnvoll und man
muss einfach sagen wir können auch im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr nicht
alles durch regulierung regeln sondern
jeder muss da auch selber ein bisschen
aufwand verwenden wir zu arbeiten muss
das verstehe ich da muss man wirklich
darauf achten dass man alternative
verkehrsmittel nutzt wo es nur geht
individuelle art ja vielleicht auch
fahrradfahren oder oder oder was einem
leben möglich ist aber eben wenn man
maske trägt wenn man nur kurz andere
leute trifft ist die ansteckungsgefahr
zwar gering aber wenn das tausendfache
kontakte sind dann trifft ein paar eben
doch wundern werden infektionen weiter
getragen und deshalb ist sowas einfach
jetzt in dieser phase auch ein problem
das heißt nach weihnachten kommt die
verschärfung wenn es nach ihnen geht
also ich glaube dass wir
weil einloggt dieser art auf dauer nicht
funktioniert dass wir mindestens in den
hotspots noch mal richtig deutliche
verschärfungen machen müssen jede region
jedes bundesland auch jeder landkreis
direkt nach meiner eine dynamik haben
die zügig auf die 50 runter geht